hi there today we'll talk about video
pre-training learning to act by watching
unlabeled online videos this is by a
team out of open ai and
is the first system that successfully
crafts a diamond pickaxe in minecraft so
apart from humans obviously so minecraft
has been sort of a test bed for
reinforcement learning algorithms all of
these years and it's notoriously hard if
you don't know what minecraft is even if
you do it is a hard hard problem so
you're in this open world and you can
essentially deconstruct any blocks so
the first thing is you want to punch a
tree right this gets you wood and you
want to craft that wood to these logs
and you craft these logs to that table
crafting is done in a menu like this
like the the top right here
the crafting interface means that you
have to arrange the items you have to
create new items there is a recipe book
but sometimes you also have to know what
you're doing then you walk around in
this open world this is not a very
competent player right here
and you can see there's a menuing
interface and so on so this is hard even
if you have like pre-defined actions but
if you don't and you just want to use
the mouse and the keyboard as this
system does right here it becomes nearly
impossible so there's a progression of
things to build you know given wooden
planks and crafting tables and sticks
sticks are missing here you can build
the wooden pickaxe with the wooden
pickaxe you can you can use that to mine
cobblestone with the cobblestone you can
then build a stone pickaxe
with the stone pickaxe you can go even
further and further
uh
here you can see a bunch of stuff that
this agent learns this is
um tap to unmute well i did it
in any case
this agent here learned to raid a
village like to look around in a village
you can see just how complex these
worlds are right there are these
villages it's an open world the terrain
is randomly generated and it's a
completely new terrain every single time
you start the game and this is why it's
so incredible look at the amount of the
items in this in this uh chest right
here so just to give you sort of an idea
of now it worked an idea of how
difficult this game is no agent has yet
managed to
successfully kind of progress through
these things uh especially no agent that
is not like has hard-coded things in in
it like that so here would be the full
progression to the diamond pickaxe see
we before we saw you get into the stone
pickaxe you can use the stone pickaxe to
mine iron ore from that you can smelt
the iron ore in a furnace to produce
iron you need something that's burnable
from that you can craft an iron pickaxe
and with the iron pickaxe you can mine
the diamond if you find the diamond now
um
the episodes the episodes here run for
10 minutes i believe or 15. we have
tried this so on our discord we
discussed this paper and thank you very
much to everyone who participated i've
tried it and it was pretty hard i got to
two diamonds once
uh within
within two diamonds within 10 minutes
or 15 and the diamond pickaxe needs
three diamonds so for a human it's
already pretty hard for a
system like this it is actually it's
it's pretty darn hard
so you can see right here if you were to
train this from a randomly initialized
model just with reinforcement learning
it doesn't work so the entire question
is how do we get this to work
in a
like in the cheapest way possible and
that's where this paper comes in
so
i think the fundamental question even
though it's called video video
pre-training which essentially means we
have a model that's pre-trained on
videos
uh the main question is here where do we
spend our money most effectively so
let's say we have a bunch of money right
so let's say here is a bucket well it's
more like a
a box okay and the box is the box has
dollars in it now these aren't as worth
as much anymore
as they used to in the good old days but
in any case how would you spend that
money right you can go and collect label
data for example so you can go to
contractors and they can play the game
all right so oopsie
you can tell them you can say okay this
much of my money that's kind of playing
i pay people to play the game i record
their actions right so and then i have a
video together with the labels the
labels being the inputs of the humans
and then i have at least a data set
where i can do something like behavior
cloning right the other thing could be i
could spend the money on getting
unlabeled data now if i spend the same
money on unlabeled data let's say this
this slice right here
unlabeled
uh
i suck at writing um
i'm going to get much more data but they
don't have labels so can i do something
with the unlabeled data
and then lastly i can spend money on
labeling itself so let's say that the
chunk here may be spent on labeling
i can also do other stuff right uh but
the question is what's the best
distribution of getting your money spent
and getting an agent that performs as
well as as possible
okay i also have to spend some money on
training the actual system but well it's
open ai they have the compute
so the way that this paper does it which
i find is quite
cool and is a good recipe for sort of
future applications of if you if you
have any problem that's in this domain
you might want to give this approach
here a try they know they are by no
means the first people who do it like
this
but they are the first to show that this
significantly reduces your cost in
getting a capable minecraft agent and
it's such a general method that it's
pretty much applicable almost anywhere
where you have this type of problem so
what are they doing they recognize a
simple fact namely that if you have a
video sequence
video frame frame frame frame right
and if you want to infer kind of what's
the next action let's say
this is the past right you are here and
you want to infer what is the next
action
that the agent is taking
essentially that requires you
to learn from the past to look back into
the past right determine the next
actions although regressive it's a
causal model and
you know
what you essentially need to do if you
let's say you watch a video of someone
playing you have to predict what's the
next action what's the next mouse
movement what's the next key press
you have to understand what they're
thinking you have to sort of look ahead
like what might they want to do next
right and then you can sort of predict
the next action this paper recognizes
it's much simpler if you already have
the entire video sequence of past and
future frames to then from all of this
look back and forward so you integrate
all the information in hindsight you can
determine much more easily what action
was in between those two frames right
because you see the future you see the
effects of the action you might even see
a little bit ahead of what the person
you know is actually doing and then you
might infer their plans and so on so
that is a much easier task to infer the
action from the hindsight situation than
doing for the action just just from the
causal situation
and this is the basis of their method
we've seen this in other places before
i've once analyzed a talk by andrei
carpati on tesla labeling and they're
doing exactly the same thing they're
saying wait if you actually have the
whole video sequence and the car is
hidden and then appears again right if
you look back in hindsight you can
determine much more easily where that
car was the entire time same idea here
so what are they doing
they are
doing two things they're collecting
labeled data first in two different ways
so the first way they collect labeled
data um
is they simply
tell contractors what color is good here
they tell contractors to play the game
as we said they sit them down and they
play for 2 000 hours of video game 2 000
hours of minecraft they just play it
while their key presses and their mouse
movements are all recorded right so
that
sorry
that gives you a data set where you can
train a system now you could run sort of
behavior cloning directly on that system
and try to get a good agent out of that
label data but no they actually train
this purple system right here so they
train a system that takes into account
future and past in a given window and
then tries to determine the action of
one of the frames in the middle they
call this the inverse dynamics model
now they
they have now a model that you can't
really build an agent with it because
the agent can never see the future but
what you can do is you can go out into
the internet and you can collect
unlabeled data
youtube in case you have noticed happens
to be full of minecraft videos even i
made a minecraft video so you know you
can go out and you can collect tons and
tons and tons of minecraft data the only
thing they have to do is they have to
collect what they call clean data so
very often there is like a streamer in
the picture like you know me right here
so this is not sorry this is not a clean
uh paper review video it's actually it
has me inside of it or there'd be like a
subscribe button somewhere or some
something like this so they also collect
a bunch of label data from from crowd
workers to classify frames to clean
minecraft footage which is minecraft
footage that has just the minecraft
interface including the the hotbar and
the the health bars and so on but not
any of the streamer information uh and
is in survival mode if you don't know
what that means just forget about it's
one of the game modes of minecraft that
most people play in the others would be
like creative mode and i don't even know
what exists
other than that
so
you want to go you want to collect
frame
labels to classify clean data you can do
that pretty cheaply in fact i think they
from
the labeled data
they
i think they run them through a resnet a
pre-trained resnet and then just train a
support vector machine to classify clean
frames from like non-clean frames which
you know is pretty simple but it works
so all the better for that
uh but then they essentially have here
70 000 hours of clean but unlabeled data
and then the trick is they just use this
inverse dynamic model to label the
unlabeled data to have pseudo labels now
this obviously requires you to have very
very accurate inverse dynamics model and
in fact they do verify and and i believe
they get over like a 90
accuracy in inferring the actions so
that's kind of a requirement but once
you have that you can pseudo label all
of this unlabeled video data
so you label that's what they say here
you label the videos with the inverse
dynamics model and that leads you to 70
000 hours of labeled data and then you
can do the behavior cloning then you can
run your classic it's not reinforcement
earnings behavior cloning essentially
learning from expert demonstrations but
they're only pseudo expert
demonstrations because the labels have
been essentially propagated from a
smaller set of expert demonstrations
they will show in their results that
this strategy
is like way cheaper you have to collect
a lot less labeled data than if you were
to go the route of behavior cloning
directly and i think that's the thing
that's applicable throughout sort of
many many many problems not only that
they can you know
so they can then train this behavior
cloning model this causal model right
here and then they can do multiple
things they can fine-tune it on like
subsets of their data
they can also fine-tune it with
reinforcement learning to achieve
certain goals and this all becomes
possible right here because this prior
just the prior of of movement right
these videos that they collect right
here they have no goal it's just people
playing the game but this prior of how
to move in this world of things that you
can do and skills acquired is so
versatile that then you can do like
reinforcement learning given a certain
task with some regularization actually
get some good results so we're going to
dive into a little bit more detail what
they do right here but this is the basic
idea it's very
simple on its face
but it is very very effective now one
thing i have to point out here is that
they keep using this term foundation
model um
and so they have different models right
here right they have this inverse
dynamics model here they have the
classifier for the clean data and the
the model that they train the behavior
cloning model that they train on the
pseudo labeled
data the large data that's what they
call the foundation model that i don't
know how much money stanford has has
given them in order to call it the
foundation model but this is essentially
the pre-trained model that then you can
either use for zero shot application or
you can use for uh fine tuning or
further uh behavior cloning on sub data
sets but it's just like i have nothing
okay i
like the name is a different debate but
just the amount of times if you read
this paper the amount of times they make
sure to use the name foundation model or
the word foundation is it's a bit over
the top i i have to admit
um you know but to each their own so if
you
uh
don't know like the the gpt series of
models and so on then it might be a good
time to look up on on that i have
several videos on that i'll just
continue and assume that you kind of
know what's going on in the
causal or auto-aggressive natural
language
modeling world
one notable difference right here if
we're talking about causal models
non-causal models and so on is that
here they don't go from the same domain
to the same domain so this is not a
because gpt3 is like text as an input
and then text as an output so you can
sort of do this autoregressive thing in
this case it's frame data as input like
short video sequences and as an output
you get actions so it's not predicting
the next frames or anything like this
but you do get the actions as an output
and then you have to work together with
the game or with the simulator in order
to actually get a sequence
all right so what what should we dive in
first maybe the model architecture would
be another good place or a good place to
start so i already told you that the
labeling model of clean versus non-clean
data is a support vector machine on
pre-trained features that's pretty
simple the inverse dynamics model the
purple one right here and the behavior
cloning model the green one are
essentially the same model except one
gets to look into the future and one
does not
so how does that model look let me see
where i get some space
again let's say you have frames of video
so i'm gonna
draw them like this okay i probably need
to draw a lot of them so
yada yada yada yada
ah
okay this was not a good idea
i hope you can recognize these are
sequential frames of videos i'm only
going to draw the inverse dynamic model
for the behavioral cloning model exactly
the same except it can't look into the
future so let's say we want to predict
the action for this frame right here
what we do first is
so at the end we want we want the action
so what we do first is we run over the
thing with a 3d convolution so
convolution usually is in 2d on images
but you if you extend the same principle
to 3d you can
you can also convolve in time so there's
a 3d convolution i believe it's a kernel
size of 5 in the time domain so that
would be a
5 by
k by k filter that runs over the
individual like
every five neighboring frames and runs
over them in a convolution
fashion so this runs over the whole
thing so what you get are essentially
another sequence of frames because if
you know from a convnet if i
let it run over a sequence or over an
image i get out an image you might have
different amount of channels and so on
which is the same here i've not drawn
the channels actually every image here
has one channel but imagine this in four
dimension okay
so you have this
then i believe each of these frames is
passed individually through a
feed-forward layer or a sequence of feet
forward layers so that you get
embeddings so each frame now has just
single vector embeddings or this is not
frame per se so each one of these frames
is obviously a combination of five
frames around it
but each combination of five frames and
they are overlapping of course you know
if you
see how convolutions work
each one of those is made into an
embedding and then obviously how how
else you have a big transformer model
big transformer model that processes all
of this kind of stuff and spits out you
know essentially whatever you want in
this case the action
to be taken they have a
bit of an action encoding scheme which
is hierarchical which i don't want to go
into because it's very minecraft
specific but they do something that the
amount of classes that you have here
doesn't blow up but also excludes like
mutually exclusive actions and so on but
that's very minecraft specific
this part right here is essentially the
video part of video pre-training like
that's how you handle or that's how they
handle video data
by doing convolution in time
mapping to embeddings then feeding into
a transformer model if you don't know
what a transformer model is i have a
good video it's called attention is all
you need and you can learn all about it
there
so the results are pretty astounding as
i said
here you can see on the left you see the
performance of the inverse dynamic model
you can see that the accuracy
in um the accuracy in actually
do they get
the correct actions out of their model
like can their model that gets to look
into the future predict the correct
actions and yes it is actually
um
it is actually
pretty good you can see
the accuracies rising up right here the
mouse
distance also getting better and better
and here is the
here is the good
well when i say
here is one of the main results so here
you can see the validation loss of the
model
now if you were to use just behavioral
cloning on the contractor data right
here is this is a function of data set
size if you were to just use the
contractor data you would
improve
but
you get much better uh loss if you use
the
inverse dynamics model
because it gets to look into the future
right it's fairly
well want to say it's fairly intuitive
that if you do get to look into the
future you become much better
at uh predicting these things
so that it makes total sense uh to train
the inverse dynamics model first and use
that to label the data so now we have
some results right here and they always
give the results in sort of this form so
at the bottom you have something like
you know the progress of training
and
these lines represent different items so
for example this one right here is a
crafting table if you remember a
crafting for a crafting table you need
to go collect wood you need to craft
wood into planks and then you need to
craft the planks into the crafting table
so all of this requires movement in the
real world hold it holding the action to
punch yes you punch a tree in minecraft
then opening the crafting menu crafting
twice by arranging different items in in
different ways so they tell you sort of
how often these things happen or you
know how much how much the agent
achieves these things so
this line here would be representing of
this item right here obviously the
higher it goes the more the better the
agent is at crafting that thing or the
more often the agent actually has
achieved crafting that thing during
evaluation
if we look at a few yeah a few more
results
they didn't take that foundation model
and the way they call it at some point
they call
they even call it foundation data which
i found
funny um
just using the word foundation all the
time
so they now take oh i can do this when
i'm in the picture
so they can now take this foundation
model and as i said they can just
measure
how often the agent achieves
either collects or crafts a given item
so the blue thing here is just the
foundation model
that they train you know just on this
data this data has no goal it's just
people playing minecraft they just put
the agent into the world and they say
and they say what can you achieve okay
it can achieve
something like well what's that basic
mining basic mining it just means uh i
guess it collects some blocks
uh pretty often the blue bars here logs
pretty often
planks well kind of sort of often but
you can already see this is a log scale
by the way right here there are other
agents that do it much much better so
what are these other agents well one of
them as you can see here is fine-tuned
on the keyword early game so they go to
youtube again and they simply filter
minecraft videos by the ones that are
also having the title or
with the keyword early game which are
usually beginner tutorials that kind of
show you know how to get off the ground
at the beginning which for a model like
this if you if you fine tune on that and
the items that we have right here they
are very basic items they're the items
that you get at the very beginning of
the game
so that data set is much more
representative of that gameplay and you
can see that from the blue to the green
bar there's like one order of magnitude
in some of these items which is pretty
huge
and then the last thing is they train
they collect another set of contractor
data and this time they tell them to
build a house so in minecraft you can
build a house which is also one of the
first things you'll do but now it's not
early game go aimless right every
youtuber does whatever now every
contractor is tasked to build a house so
we are now in the
really behavior cloning setting with a
goal
and
yeah that's that's what we do so the
data set is targeted towards building a
house and naturally the items that you
need to build a house i guess the stone
the stone tools yeah it's pretty good to
have stone tools not necessary but
pretty good
uh but it's at least the like the wooden
tools are also pretty handy when
building a house and you can see that
all of the items that you need right
here are much higher there's like an
increase of 213
x in uh crafting tables
uh all of this essentially means that if
your data set is more appropriate you'll
get sort of more
behavior like the data set i guess
however all of this
is
fine-tuned or behavior cloned on top of
the foundation model so they first train
that pre-trained model i keep saying
foundation model myself see the
marketing gets me uh they they train on
this first thing and then
after that on top of that they either do
the fine tuning to the early game data
set or the fine tuning to the house
building or as we shall see
um they do
reinforcement learning so on top of
i believe this is on top of the early
game model they now do fine-tuning so
the early game model gets to somewhere
maybe here
i think it gets to like the stone tools
right
and then
they
do reinforcement learning
while giving rewards for collecting each
each of the items in the sequence right
here with different weights and so on
there's a fair bit of reward shaping
going on right here so i guess you can
criticize that but reward shaping has
always been the case in minecraft people
have done much harder reward shaping for
minecraft than this and they've never
achieved anything right so the ability
of this model to actually get to the
diamond pixel pickaxe over here is
astounding so this here is what happens
um
if you simply
this this
this plot right here it's just flexing
right it's it's pretty useless if you
just have a randomly initialized model
and you just do reinforcement learning
with their reward shaping and all
you're you're at zero all the lines are
at zero it achieves absolutely nothing
right
if you actually re reinforcement learn
from that pre-trained model that's been
pre-trained on just the full data set of
minecraft footage you see that you get
pretty far right you get even you get to
the furnace actually right here but the
higher tools are still not in reach even
after reinforcement learning so if you
then reinforcement learn from the
early game model so you do pre-training
you do
behavior cloning on early game filtered
keyword videos and on top of that you do
reinforcement learning with the reward
shaping you can see that you actually do
get to diamonds and to the diamond
pickaxe which is you need three diamonds
for in 2.5
of the evaluation runs and
keep in mind as far as i understand
although i have not seen this in the
paper maybe it's in the appendix or
maybe i've
missed it but this is a random seed so
the world as i said is different for
every episode that's really the hard
part right here
um that the world is so complex and
different
so
that is is pretty cool now we can draw a
bunch of conclusions from this i think
you know the fact that there is such the
fact that there is a big difference
between this and this or this and the
bottom two
it does speak highly for you know this
approach where
you want to have a lot of labeled data
in order to pre-train a model and on the
basis of that you can do reinforcement
learning and from before we know that
it's way cheaper if you first collect
small set of label data use the fact
that you can look into the future
to label unlabeled data and then use
that as your bigger label data set
however there is also a difference
between this one and this one right here
right
because just pre-training
and then doing reinforcement learning
doesn't seem to be enough to reach the
highest tools right here
it also pays off to really have an
appropriate pre-training so when you do
further pre-training essentially on
early game footage then
that is much more conducive on the way
to getting a diamond pickaxe which i
guess to some minecraft players is late
game but to most is still also kind of
early game
to get your first diamond tools
and
that is also pretty pretty interesting
so it is
not
it is not
the case that you can just go out and
get any sort of data that you want
obviously more is always better but
having the appropriate data is also very
very important so whatever you can do to
get that and maybe add that then on top
of the
of the full uh random data that's kind
of the best strategy
at least from this from this chart right
here
so they do a bunch of uh more
experiments right here um to for example
see the effect of the 3d convolutions
see the effect of the inverse dynamics
model of the quality of that like what
if you train it um better or with more
data and so on but essentially that's
the paper in a nutshell and yeah as i
said it's pretty simple it's certainly
not something that no one has done
before in principle however it is a
pretty good demonstration of something
in practice like
making a capable minecraft agent
no one has done that
this is quite a significant jump i have
i i believe
and
the idea here not only to do that
because i'm pretty sure openai could
have just paid for like tons and tons of
data in order to do that um but in order
like doing that while giving us a recipe
you know here is how you can kind of
save a ton of money
again they're not the first to do it but
they demonstrate quite nicely that in a
situation like this it can make quite
the difference
yeah and
lastly i do believe they
make their model available there is a mi
there's the competition mind rl if
you're interested in that that's a
minecraft reinforcement learning
competition and you can take their model
and you can fine tune that
at your heart's content so you don't
have to do that whole video pre-training
because that's like the training itself
is pretty expensive i
i thought somewhere
so the inverse okay i've lost that but i
think the inverse dynamics model
training was already quite a bit vroom
vroom but then
let's see fine tuning
ah i'm not gonna find it i'm not gonna
find it right oh there we go
oh it took nine days on 720
v100 gpus
that's a big number that's that's a lot
of v100 gpus
geez
yeah so they've done that for you you
can take their model you can fine tune
it you can uh modify it and so on so uh
pl please do that and if you have if you
happen to have spare gpus you can you
can send me you can send them to me no
problem all right that was it from me uh
stay hydrated
see you around bye